einen schönen sonntag euch allen und
willkommen zu heute live und man kann
eigentlich nur hoffen dass ihr euch ein
gemütliches plätzchen organisiert habt
um unsere live stream zu verfolgen denn
der winter hat weite teile deutschlands
ziemlich fest im griff
es ist ungemütlich zumindest im norden
und in der mitte deutschland es ging los
in der nach zum beispiel in thüringen wo
lkw im schnee steckenblieben und auch
heute tagsüber in nrw und niedersachsen
wo schneeverwehungen beispielsweise bei
hannover den betrieb auf den autobahnen
lahmlegten oder zumindest erheblich
verzögerten dazu kam in vielen gegenden
gefährlicher eisregen der fast alles mit
einem klirrenden panzer überzug und noch
vieles mehr dazu dann später im laufe
der sendung und ihr könnt gerne
mitmachen wie immer fragen und
kommentare
an diese adresse bzw die die sonst auch
immer gilt
wir sprechen mit vier reporter innen
über die wettersituation in deutschland
sprechen nachher auch noch mit östlichen
teil ii unseren zdf wetterexperten und
der wird euch dann auch die fragen die
er womöglich habt dann gerne und so gut
es geht beantworten zunächst aber
schauen wir in die nähe von hildesheim
in niedersachsen zu meinem kollegen
oliver deuker der steht nämlich an der
autobahn genauer an der a7
oliver was geht bei euch beziehungsweise
was geht momentan nicht naja ich sags
mal so eingeschränkt geht eigentlich
fast alles um so zu formulieren
der verkehr läuft wobei der verkehr ist
und man sieht dass er auch ganz gut
eigentlich nicht ganz wenig los auf der
a7 das liegt natürlich daran dass zum
einen sonntag geht es halt nicht so viel
los auf der anderen seite haben gab es
ja die sturmwarnung die unwetter
warnungen also haben sich viele leute
das geschenk dann mit dem auto unterwegs
zu sein das merkt man auch deutlich aber
auf der a7 hier und ganzes stück weiter
60 70 kilometer richtung süden
das bin ich heute schon gefahren dieses
stück ist eine geschlossene schneedecke
hier und da guckt vielleicht mal so ein
bisschen asphalt durch aber im großen
und ganzen kann man eigentlich nur auf
der rechten spur fahren die meisten
leute fahren sehr vernünftig relativ
langsam mit tempo 60 80 geht's über die
autobahnen park ist natürlich immer die
übertreiben etwas ich bin heute morgen
gestartet in hannover da war auch
wirklich auf den großen
strecken noch auf den
hauptverkehrsrouten komplett dichte
schneedecke und nichts los sonntagmorgen
wie gesagt letztendlich aber die
räumfahrzeuge kommen eigentlich kaum
nach und das ist auch hier auf der a7
hier wurde schon einmal geräumt aber
durch die schneeverwehungen wird das
dann immer wieder der schnee auf die
autobahn geblasen oder auf die straßen
und dann gibt es probleme und dann
teilweise einigen stücken geben zb bei
bockenem da ist eine richtung hannover
das 30 kilometer von ihr entfernt dass
ein teilabschnitte autobahnen gesperrt
da ist dann kein wald rechts und links
wie hier da bläst es dann ordentlich und
dann geht der schnee wieder auf die
straße deshalb hat man das dann dicht
gemacht
dieses stück und naja die lkw und alle
anderen fahrzeuge die die a7 richtung
hannover runterfahren müssen müssen dann
ausreichend über die landstraßen
ich musste das dann auch machen ich
glaube mich dreimal festgefahren viele
lkw die in den schneewehen
hängengeblieben sind zum teil
räumfahrzeuge viel unterwegs also ich
sage mal kein chaos aber durchaus nerven
strapazieren das ganze und relativ
eingeschränkt ja das kann ich mir
vorstellen man sieht auch bei diesem
hintergrund den schnee der da verweht
wird also das sieht schon heftig aus
auch gerade auf den bildern das war
schon so auch von alaska oder sibirien
da aus niedersachsen
das war jetzt die situation sozusagen
auf den straßen was ist denn mit dem
bahnverkehr oder dem öffentlichen
nahverkehr ist zum teil der bahnverkehr
schon zum erliegen gekommen und sowohl
die deutsche bahn aber auch die privaten
unternehmen metronom und wie sie nicht
alle heißen also das sind da etliche
routen eingestellt wurden
richtung süden raus aber auch richtungen
norden draußen paar fahren noch die s
bahn in hannover
da ist der verkehr komplett eingestellt
worden auf den bahnhöfen selber die
menschen haben sich darauf eingerichtet
da sind sicherlich ein paar hängen
geblieben die weiter wollten oder die
von daraus los wollte aber im großen und
ganzen sage ich mal läuft es bei der
bahn logischerweise nicht so gut das
hauptproblem sind einfach die
eingefrorenen weichen die braucht man
nun mal vorschlägen bei den bahnhöfen um
dann auf die entsprechend gleis zu
kommen da gibt es probleme auf der einen
seite ich habe mit dem
metronom pressesprecher telefoniert der
sagte mir naja wir fahren elektrisch
dass unser nächstes problem die hoch
leitungen die sind zum teil eingefroren
viel schlimmer aber eigentlich dass die
gleise gefroren sind nicht dass da die
lokomotiven nicht drüberfahren könnten
aber man fährt elektrisch und da braucht
man strom für ist muss geerdet werden
das geht dann bei heißt nicht mehr also
kann man die züge dort dann auch nicht
einsetzen und die sind häufig mit
solchen e zügen unterwegs letztendlich
so diesellok mag das noch schaffen
können obwohl eben auch auf den gleisen
durchaus schneeverwehungen da sind also
sehr eingeschränkter bahnverkehr ja
insgesamt also noch ein bisschen muss
man doch sagen gefahrenpotenzial
dankeschön oliver reuter für diese
eindrücke aus niedersachsen passt gut
auf euch auf ja und bei mir ist jetzt es
den terli zdf metereologe natürlich
bekannt aus den einschlägigen sendungen
es denn schnee anfang februar in
deutschland das klingt jetzt erstmal
nicht besonders ungewöhnlich aber doch
man kann sagen wir haben es im moment
mit einer nicht ganz alltäglichen
wetterlage zu tun
ja es ist ja diese grenze wetterlage von
der wir auch die fast die ganze woche
über wir meteorologen gesprochen haben
wo quasi die kalte luft aus dem
nordosten kommt und warme luft dagegen
und grenz wetterlage deswegen weil sich
diese luftmassengrenze nicht verschiebt
sie bleibt quasi stecken über
deutschland und dann komm permanent
kalte luft aus dem nordosten und relativ
milder aus dem südwesten und diese
luftmasse die aus dem südwesten quasi
herangeführt wird die ist halt relativ
warm und feucht und so kommt es eben an
der grenze zum beispiel jetzt an diesem
wochenende zu extremen schneefällen wir
hatten ja die ganze woche das immer
wieder dass mit diesen mit dieser
grenzwerte lage aber jetzt dieses tief
hat nun wirklich enorm feuchte luft
dagegen gedrückt und es hat sich halt
auch eine stimmlage quasi also kann er
richtig heftige sturm lag aber es gab
ordentlichen ostwind und dieser ostwind
hat den schnee im verweht und das ist
schon eine besondere geschichte
jetzt ist es ja so dass werden besondere
wetterlagen auftauchen und man sich
immer gleich die frage stellt steht das
in irgend einem größeren zusammenhang
klimawandel erderwärmung wie ist da
deine antwort ja also man muss ja erst
einmal sagen das letzte mal dass es so
was ähnliches gab dass die luft die die
druck gebilde sage ich mal tiefs und
hochs ähnlich lagen das war ja 78 79 und
da hatten wir auch so eine grenz
wetterlage das war allerdings ein
katastrophenfall bei weitem schlimmer
als das was wir jetzt erleben
und damals war die luft macht ja auch
deutlich kälter die es in der arktis gab
die arktis hat sich ja dreimal stärker
erwärmt als der rest des planeten und
somit haben wir dort gar nicht mehr
diese eisiger diese extrem kalte sophie
sie vor 40 über 40 jahren vorhanden war
ja und dementsprechend ist vielleicht
die auswirkungen da nicht ganz so
schlimm aber insgesamt kann man das
natürlich nicht irgendwie beiseite
wischen es gibt ja immer wieder dann die
amüsante frage ist jetzt der klimawandel
vorbei oder ist die klimakrise durch
weil es mal kalt ist oder weil es mal
schneit da steht da gibt es natürlich
keinen das ist natürlich kein grund
jahrzehntelanger trend der erwärmung der
lässt sich nicht mit einem mal auch mit
einer extremen schneelage quasi
wegwischen zumal ja es wechselwirkungen
mit der atmosphäre mit den oberen
luftschichten gibt mit den unteren und
wenn zum beispiel eine eine studie
besagt oder eine richtung besagt dass es
die eisfreiheit in der arktis durch die
klimakrise bedingt dass der polarwirbel
start oder sich dann verschiebt und
dadurch halte es zu solchen kaltluft
ausbrechen kann
also das ist ein bereich der erforscht
wird und dann direkt quasi der
klimakrise zusammenhängt okay gut also
das sind jetzt natürlich weitere fragen
die jetzt deutlich über deutschlands
grenzen hinaus erreichen wir wollen
gerade nochmal unsere user auch mit ins
boot nehmen
lacher fragt wie e-mail ist es ratsam
morgen mit dem auto von berlin nach
rheinland pfalz zu fahren also wir
hatten jetzt auch vor der sendung gesagt
wir wollen jetzt nicht die wetter fragen
und detail für jeden einzelnen
bezirk in deutschland besprechen das
können wir auch gar nicht leisten das
kannst du auch nicht leisten generell
ist es aber wohl so dass man sagen kann
ok also größere autofahrten jetzt über
land morgen von berlin beispielsweise
nach rheinland pfalz vielleicht nicht
unbedingt
ja nicht unbedingt die frage ist
überhaupt ob man vorwärts kommt also wir
haben ja die bilder gerade gesehen da
ist ja einiges los und die kommen der
nacht wird ja eisig kalt und von berlin
aus ich muss gerade mir die
wettermodelle überlegen wie sie liegen
also wenn man von berlin aus über fährt
also das wird keine lustige fahrt also
man muss ja auch sehr konzentriert
fahren es ist eis bedeckt schnee bedeckt
und wenn die temperaturen noch relativ
tief sind und das wird ja auch so
bleiben ist die rutschgefahr halt immer
groß also diesen stress würde ich mir
gar nicht geben
gut danke öffnen wir sprechen gleich
weitermachen aber jetzt zunächst weiter
im bergischen land bei reporterin nummer
zwei dort steht nämlich carsten edinger
und casting die frage wie ist die lage
bei euch ja es ist frostig kalt hier ich
stehe hier am rande eines waldstücks
mitten im bergischen land und heute
nacht hat es hier weniger geschneit
sondern es gab viel mehr eisregen und
das hat diese landschaft in eine
wunderschöne landschaft verwandelt es
ist hier alles die äste und zweige die
sind hier mit einer dicken eisschicht
überzogen
das sieht man hier auch das sind
ungefähr vier zentimeter und das ist
wirklich enorm aber so romantisch wie
das aussieht ist das gar nicht denn als
wir hier auf dem weg hierher hierher
gefahren sind haben wir auch viele äste
und zweige gesehen wie hier auf dem
boden lagen also wer jetzt meint einen
winterspaziergang machen zu müssen dem
kann man davon abraten
denn im wald besteht lebensgefahr
aber generell haben sich die leute hier
im umkreis sehr vernünftig verhalten ich
habe vorhin mit der polizei telefoniert
und die hat gesagt die leute sind zu
hause geblieben
es gab tatsächlich nur einen
witterungsbedingten unfall gestern und
heute nacht besorgt ist man lediglich
über die oberleitungen man hat ein wenig
angst dass sie unter dieser ice last
zusammenbrechen könnten und das ist
tatsächlich auch schon in gummersbach
passiert dort ist heute morgen für
ungefähr eine stunde in einigen teilen
der strom ausgefallen
ja es gab du bist jetzt schon bei den
sozusagen einzelereignissen ja auch in
deiner nähe
ein paar vorkommen dass wir die bereits
für schlagzeilen gesorgt haben unter
anderem auch in wuppertal
ja genau in wuppertal war es so dass
heute morgen die wuppertaler schwebebahn
stehen geblieben ist das heißt die
schienen waren so vereist dass sie nicht
mehr weiterfahren konnte und es gab noch
sechs passagiere die mit der feuerwehr
über eine drehleiter gerettet werden
mussten ein weiterer vorfall
den gab es in hagen dort campiert schon
seit längerer zeit ein zirkus und dort
brach das zirkuszelt unter der ganzen
schnee und eislast zusammen und darunter
befanden sich 13 tiere aber auch die
konnten glücklicherweise gerettet werden
also zusammenfassend kann man von hier
sagen das bergische land ist momentan
einer katastrophe von einer katastrophe
noch sehr weit entfernt
möge es so bleiben vielen dank für diese
eindrücke ins bergische land vielen dank
kers den edinger und weiter geht direkt
die wilde fahrt nach magdeburg denn dort
ist nur die sachen für uns im einsatz
und natürlich auch da die frage luisa
dick eingemummelt wie stark tobt der
winter war ich ja es ist frostig kalt
hier und man kann sagen der winter hat
die stadt lahmgelegt wir stehen hier
gerade wo eigentlich die straßenbahn
fährt hier in beide richtungen durch die
stadt aber durch den schnee sind die
schienen komplett bedeckt
und ja die schneewehen sorgen dafür dass
auch jeder versuch irgendwie was
freizuräumen missglückt auch jeder der
versucht vor der tür irgendwie den
schnee wegzuschaffen kann sobald er
fertig ist wieder von vorne anfangen
kann man sagen es hat im harz bis zu 30
zentimeter schnee gegeben hier in
magdeburg sind 15 cm gewesen und auch in
anderen städten wie zum beispiel in
halle oder in dessau die straßen
verkehrs betriebe die ihre arbeit
eingestellt und wir wollen versuchen
wohl heute noch irgendwie ist alles frei
zu räumen aber ja das ist die vorarbeit
aktuell weil es hier wirklich der wind
dafür sorgt dass immer wieder alles
verweht und das sorgt wohl auch dafür
dass also wenig menschen unterwegs sind
ich habe ein paar leute gesehen die
wahrheit im schlitten unterwegs oder
haben sich auch auf skiern raus getraut
aber weil es hier so kalt ist und der
wind so fies weht sind doch die meisten
wohl zu hause geblieben und dem rat
gefolgt sich in sicherheit zu bringen
also auch dort überwiegend vernünftiges
bürger verhalten habt ihr denn aller
voraussicht nach das schlimmste schon
hinter euch also hier wird es weiter
schneiden hier wird es auch weiter eisig
kalt und windig bleiben bis zu minus 15
grad hat der wetterdienst angekündigt
und ich habe auch mit den
verkehrsbetrieben telefoniert und
gefragt ob sie denn glauben dass es
morgen zum berufsverkehr hier wieder
frei sein wird und die straßenbahnen
wieder fahren könnten
und sie haben gesagt ja sie versuchen
wohl sie schicken heute schneepflüge
raus die dafür sorgen sollen dass hier
die wege wieder frei werden
wir werden es versuchen aber als ob das
wirklich glück ist unwahrscheinlich
vielen dank flüsse haben wir drücken
natürlich auch euch die daumen das ist
euch nicht allzu hart erwischte in den
nächsten tagen dankeschön und wir
sprechen weiter mit unseren
wetterexperten mit es den terli es denn
wir haben ja unsere user frage auch
immer mit in der sendung da schreibt zum
beispiel horst hund können wir darauf
hoffen dass die grenzwerte lagen noch
länger weitergeht bzw was muss passieren
dass sagt franzi wie bei facebook dass
sich diese grenzwerte lage auflöst ja
eigentlich bräuchten wir einen sehr
strammen eine sehr strenge westströmung
quasi das dass die kälte ausgeräumt wird
aber es sieht genau nach im gegenteil
aus also es kommt eher wahrscheinlich im
laufe der woche noch etwas kältere luft
voran aus dem norden und osten und das
würde wiederum bedeuten dass dass der
gefallene schnee quasi auch nicht
wegschaut und liegen bleibt also diese
winterlichen verhältnisse werden erst
einmal bleiben und die kältere luft die
uns erreicht die dehnt sich dann auch
weiter ein bisschen weiter in den süden
aus also das ist jetzt nicht durch die
ganze geschichte
ich kann
ich kann euch auch mal hier kurz eine
unsere aktuelle wetter karte zeigen die
quasi heute auch in den
nachrichtensendungen zu sehen sein wird
und da sehen wir ja da tut sich wenig
wenn man sich die farbverteilung
anschaut glaube ist relativ dunkles blau
ist hauptsächlich im osten zu finden das
bedeutet hier sind die tiefsten
temperaturen und die kälte dehnt sich
auch bis donnerstag weiter in den süden
aus man sieht auch die temperaturen
gehen zurück also dann am donnerstag nur
noch minus zehn bis minus 1 grad wohl
gemerkt dass die höchsttemperaturen
natürlich aber ja man muss sagen unter
einer anderen lage hätte ich gesetz
gesagt völlig normal weil wir sind in
der kältesten zeit des jahres also eher
dass hier als diese sehr milde luft die
wir letzte woche zum beispiel in südwest
mit 14 grad das ist ziemlich normal
jetzt haben wir diese kalte luft und das
passt schon
ja unter dazu kommt halt häufiger die
sonne hervor
er ist ja auch auf unserer karte schon
untergebracht haben also insgesamt
müssen wir mit der kälte weiterleben und
die schneemassen die liegen bleiben erst
mal liegen ja eigentlich hast du
vollkommen recht also man hat sich
irgendwie so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt
in den letzten jahren dass es zumindest
in der mitte deutschland wir sind hier
in mainz nicht mehr besonders kalt wird
jetzt haben wir zweistellige minusgrade
aber eigentlich ja auch ein normales
phänomen wir kriegen noch mal die frage
inwieweit wir gerade ein besonderes
wetterereignis erleben du hast es schon
gesagt also zum einen ist es natürlich
schon so dass man im februar öfter mal
kaltes wetter hat und auch schnee aber
nicht so viel wie im moment ja das ist
jetzt sagen wir mal von von der
gesamtkonstellation ist es einfach
spannend dass sich die luftmassen
solange gegenüberstehen und jetzt
kommt's ja so dazu dass die kalte luft
sicher da nun auch durchsetzt
jetzt gibt es diese grenzwerte lage in
dem sinne ja nicht mehr so kommt die
kalte luft voran
und deswegen wird der schnee auch
nachlassen nur morgen noch nicht morgen
und auch in der kommenden nacht gibt es
teilweise richtung franken und ein wenig
südlich davon gibt es noch kräftige
schneefälle also 25 bis 30 zentimeter
und so ein bisschen aus meteorologischer
sicht ein bisschen erzählt das war zum
beispiel vor drei tagen so nicht
absehbar dass da jetzt tatsächlich
nochmal so viel schnee dazu
und in dieser region und das ist dabei
jetzt in den modellen drin und wird wohl
so stattfinden wir sind gespannt wir
reden gleich nochmal weiter es denn wir
kommen zu unserer letzten reporter
station und die befindet sich in erfurt
dort steht meine kollegin daniela
sonntag auch daniela natürlich an dich
zuerst die frage wie ist die lage den
regenschirm kann ich schon sehen ganz
genau die lager ist vor allen dingen
kalt wir stehen jetzt hier in erfurt und
eigentlich würde man jetzt hier hinter
mir erfurt sehen und wie man sieht sieht
man gar nichts mehr
und das ist im moment in thüringen an
vielen stellen so thüringen liegt ja
genau in der mitte
dieser grenzwert lage also wir haben auf
der einen seite so in südthüringen
wetter wo es vor allen dingen sehr kalt
ist im norden schneit unheimliche in
erfurt schnäuz jetzt auch ganz schön und
das hat jetzt schon in den letzten tagen
hier zu einigen unfällen geführt also
die polizei hat gezählt insgesamt über
100 unfälle wobei man sagen muss
insgesamt ist das ganz große chaos
tatsächlich noch ausgeblieben
also viele leute haben eben doch auf die
warnungen gehört viele leute in
thüringen auch die so ein bisschen
winter erfahren sind haben gesagt okay
wir bleiben zu hause
es war auch das wochenende und man hat
eben heute auf den straßen wirklich
wenig verkehr gesehen dafür unheimlich
viele leute die mit skiern unterwegs
waren
und als ich jetzt hierher gefahren bin
heute kamen mir mitten in der innenstadt
in erfurt jemand auf dem snowboard
entgegen also das war schon etwas
surreal bizarre bilder aber andererseits
das ist ja vielleicht noch als positiv
zu werten morgen dann zu beginn der
woche setzt aber normalerweise ja auch
der berufsverkehr wieder ein ist da denn
dann verschafft mit problemen zu rechnen
also morgen sieht die lage noch mal
anders aus zum einen ist es ja so wenn
das wetter jetzt so bleibt wird das
schwierig auf den straßen jetzt ist es
schon so gewesen dass der winterdienst
zum teil nicht durchgekommen ist in
erfurt ist heute unter anderem der
schneepflug der straßenbahn entgleist
weil zu viel schnee auf den schienen lag
da wird es gefährlich auch die bar auch
für die bahnfahrer ist das nicht so
einfach erfurt ist ja ein
verkehrsknotenpunkt einer der
wichtigsten für die bahn
da ist schon vieles eingestellt abellio
ein regionalanbieter hat komplett den
verkehr eingestellt auf dem erfurter
bahnhof mussten zum teil die
treppenaufgänge
wegen schneeverwehungen geschlossen
werden und da ist morgen noch einiges zu
erwarten und da machen sich auch viele
sorgen thüringen hat jetzt zum beispiel
auch verfügt dass alle schulen morgen
geschlossen bleiben weil sie
ursprünglich war es ja so dass zumindest
für die abschlussklassen die schulen
offenbaren dass die zwölftklässler die
zehntklässer die ihre abschlüsse machen
dort hingehen können dass es morgen
alles geschlossen um eben weniger
verkehr auf die straße zu bringen
und jeder der morgen im home-office
bleiben kann sollte da vermutlich auch
besser bleiben
da ist also noch mal die eindrücke aus
thüringen erfurt vielen dank daniela
sonntag für diese schilderung und auch
an euch natürlich alles gute und passt
auf euch auf und wir wollen noch mal den
blick weiten auf ja das gesamte
bundesgebiet denn es ist ein
ungewöhnlicher wintereinbruch im norden
zumindest und in der mitte für anfang
februar selbst dass mein kollege jürgen
kehl gibt uns noch mal einen überblick
über das bisher geschehene
ich höre gerade er ist nicht da und
gesehen haben wir ihn auch nicht wir
hoffen dass wir ihnen gleich nach
reichen können den beitrag des kollegen
kinder machen wir weiter mit rtl ii der
bei uns im studio ist unser zdf
wetterexperte jetzt ist ein klang ist
ein bisschen so als ob fast der ein oder
andere ja etwas enttäuscht gewesen wäre
dass es dann doch nicht so hart gekommen
ist wie es vorher gesagt war
wie ist deine einschätzung so logan
haben ja klar darauf hingewiesen 20 bis
30 zentimeter verbreitet bis 50 sind
drin und mit verwehungen das ist ja dann
schwierig wenn er sind quasi rheinfalls
und den wind irgendwo anhäuft also dass
die wetterlage durchaus lebensgefährlich
sein kann und zu problemen führt sehen
wir ja ich meine werden jetzt ganz viele
menschen unterwegs gewesen wären ohne
die warnungen muss man sich ja überlegen
was dann passiert wäre
aber ich glaube im vorfeld wurde ganz
schön viel gehabt katastrophenfall und
so weiter das ist nicht gekommen und das
haben wir auch so nicht gesagt dennoch
finde ich diese wetterlage weiterhin
kann durchaus lebensgefährlich sagen man
muss auch daran denken dass auch
obdachlose menschen gibt die draußen
leben oder man braucht sich nur
vorzustellen man fällt irgendwo hin ist
bewusstlos
das ist eine wetterlage wo man dann
wirklich oben sein leben dann angst
haben müsste naja enttäuschung war
natürlich auch in anführungszeichen
scheint also wir sind natürlich alle
positiv überrascht wenn überhaupt das
ist dann vielleicht nicht ganz so arg
gekommen ist aber noch ist die gefahr ja
auch nicht ausgestanden
tausendschön über facebook mit der frage
wie sieht es mit der hochwasserlage aus
wenn das alles wieder schmilzt das ist
ja auch eine interessante frage das
betrifft jetzt mehr den süden
deutschlands auch na ja also klar wenn
das alles schmilzt dann läuft es in die
flüsse rhein aber davon ist jetzt erst
einmal überhaupt keine dass das ist
überhaupt nicht in sichtweite erste maat
auf wetter also nach heutigem stand
sieht es eher aus dass es kalt bleibt
und vielleicht sogar noch eine kältere
luftmasse uns erreicht dass es auch noch
in aussicht und man muss sagen das sind
ja nicht nur die tageswerte die so als
ich sind tagsüber geht es in der mitte
über große flächen unter -10 und -15
grad zurück
also das ist schon eine kälte die wir
sagen wir mal in den letzten jahren
nicht so häufig hatten aufgrund der
allgemeinen erwärmung
also ist jetzt für uns sagen wir mal
nach so langer zeit auch etwas
besonderes
holger thiel aus gütersloh fragt uns via
e-mail inwieweit spielen bei der
vorhersage diese ereignisse die
entwicklungen in der raumfahrt eine
rolle sagt man heute das wetter
schneller und sicherer vorher als noch
vor zum beispiel 20 jahren ja also klar
die modelle haben sich gebessert wir
haben deutlich bessere computer und
deutlich bessere auswertungen und die
wettervorhersagen sind einfach besser
geworden das muss man sagen und wir
haben in deutschland aber auch
international sieht man das auch in
anderen ländern in frankreich oder
weiter in skandinavien da gibt es
einfach gut waren möglichkeiten also der
deutsche wetterdienst hat ja auf seiner
seite wir können auch kurz mal drauf
gucken ich habe das gerade hier
aufgerufen
die warnseite quasi unter sehen wir auch
was ich eben meinte hier richtung
franken
und wir hatten ja eben die schalter auch
nach erfurt und hier ist es hier gibt's
vorwarnungen dass es dieser gestreifte
bereich das bedeutet dass wir da schon
mit besonderem wetter zu rechnen haben
mit unwetter starken schneefall
schneeverwehungen
diese seite kann ich empfehlen für alle
die mal kurz gucken wollen
wie sieht es denn aus und hier steht ja
auch zum beispiel örtlich bis 25 cm
ich habe eben noch auf ein modell
geschaut und das zeigte mir auch
durchaus 30 und vielleicht noch darüber
und das innerhalb der jetzt kommenden
nacht also kommen noch ja die kommen
noch mal in diesem schraffierten bereich
ist es möglich also dass ist wirklich
noch nicht ausgestanden und das kann
noch mal die situation verschärfen
tja wenn jetzt dieses virus nicht
kassieren würde dann könnte man ja sagen
rudel auf dem fahrrad fahren gut bzw
skifahren aber das ist ja momentan alles
nicht anzuraten beziehungsweise auch
verboten ist denn ich frage gleich
nochmal nach den aussichten bzw würde
vorher aber noch mal wissen wollen ob
wir denn jetzt noch mal den rückblick
machen wollen frage an die regie oder
machen wir weiter mit dem ausblick ok
wir versuchen es später noch mal es
dennoch mal mit der frage nach dem
ausblick für die kommenden
es ist für ihn schon angedeutet also es
ist mit weiterem schneefall zu rechnen
welche teile deutschlands kann man das
sagen haben es dennoch so am dicksten
vorsicht ja das ist also wirklich dieses
nördliche bayern franken und sachsen
sachsen anhalt zum teil noch da kommt
noch einiges an schnee zusammen das wird
jetzt in der kommenden nacht der fall
sein und morgen am montag gibt es auch
noch weitere schneefälle das wird aber
nicht mehr so stark sein
es bezieht sich dann hauptsächlich auf
bayern und auch ein bisschen nach westen
es kann sein dass wir hier die der wärme
uns quasi immer venen in rheinland-pfalz
dass wir auch noch ein zwei zentimeter
schnee bekommen ist jetzt nicht die
menge aber es ist eben so dass die der
schnee sich ein bisschen weiter nach
süden ausbreitet und dann auch
allmählich nachlässt und ich habe es
eben auch schon angeschnitten die nächte
sind halt über schnee dann besonders
kalt also den regionen wo schnee liegt
und vor allem in der mitte deutschlands
auch noch welt nach westen wo man es
eigentlich nicht so gewöhnt ist der
import uhr - 10 -12 grad minus 15 grad
zum beispiel nach niedersachsen oder
nach brandenburg hin
da gehen die temperaturen in den nächten
kräftig zurück und die höchsten
temperaturen mit minus 10 grad im osten
deutschlands das ist schon ist schon
eine hausmarke also das reicht um doch
kalte füße zu bekommen ist das jetzt
momentan ja kein deutsches phänomen
nämlich mal an sondern diese wetterlage
betrifft ja auch unsere nachbarländer
ist denn da teilweise auch mit schlimmen
oder extremen wettersituationen zu
rechnen also eher nach osten hin erst
einmal im westen ist es noch nicht so
kalt das ist eben die frage ob sich die
kalte luft durchsetzen wird in den
nächsten tagen also das ist jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen weit in die
zukunft geschaut richtung wochenende da
könnt ihr nochmal ne deutlich kältere
luftmasse kommen und die würde dann war
aus dem osten kommen und vielleicht
danach nord drehen also da ist noch
musik im winter sage ich mal
das ist noch nicht abgeschrieben es ist
auch nicht der letzte schnee den wir
sehen ja also zackig wie man in bayern
sagt einigermaßen gar nicht vielen dank
es denn für diese ausführung und
analysen und wir sind gespannt wie sich
das wetter weiter entwickelt euch an
dieser stelle auch noch mal ein
herzliches dankeschön für eure fragen
wir haben kein und weiteren ich habe
gerade noch mal geschaut ja also wenn
ihr die möglichkeit habt dann bei
besser zu hause zumindest dann wenn ihr
in den betroffenen regionen wohnt und
das sind ja doch einige wie wir jetzt in
dieser sendung gelernt haben also euch
ein herzliches dankeschön einen schönen
sonntag noch und bis zum nächsten live
stream